podcast nation what is good uh very
special episode today i i believe this
man will have
no need for an introduction we have mark
zuckerberg i have to start practicing
this mark i've been in a bunch of
meetings saying meta uh you know just a
lot of practice you really threw me for
a curveball yeah i'm still getting used
to it too
so uh
obviously uh
mark is at the hell and the head of meta
uh and um
and i'm really excited to be talking to
him because i really want to get into
the metaverse and the web3 world
obviously so much of this community is
aware
of uh
of uh my involvement in the nft space
and it's funny on the way here i
realized oh my god this interview is
going to go similar to the joe namath
interview i had
for all my
my uh
sports nerd friends that listened to
this podcast when i had namethon
i literally asked him 14 questions that
were so left field compared to the
normal joe namath questions for example
i asked him about why we lost the afc
championship game and didn't go to super
bowl four instead of talking about super
bowl three and i realized that's what's
gonna happen here because i have so many
very selfish questions
for mark about this web 3 world that i'm
going to be selfish with my limited time
with him so mark first of all it's good
to see you and how are you
it's good to see you too it's um you
know it's been a while since we've done
something like this but i'm i'm glad to
get a chance to do it there's a lot of
exciting stuff going on right now so and
i am you know the reason why we come to
you is is is because you do ask good
questions so so let's go for it i'm
curious what you got for me
so mark i think um what's really funny
in the meta pun intended it's nftnyc
right now and i was saying to aj kevin
rose a bunch of the old web 2.0 friends
how much this feels like the early south
by southwest days
and obviously
the one of the first times we sat down
was uh
was after your keynote at south by
just jamming talking about the space and
i remember the conversation vividly
because i have a solid memory and
because a lot of things we talked about
about where this was all going
was the topic and many of these things
played out as somebody that i feel has
always had a disproportionate
understanding of communication consumer
you know human behavior um
give me your first hot take i know
you've had this big you know
uh announcement the other day what is
your just kind of macro thesis of the
web3 place we're going whether it's the
metaverse the nft stuff like what are we
on the precipitous of and how similar is
it to the time
where right before facebook uh was
launched
yeah so
the the metaverse to me today feels like
the next
frontier in social connection in much
the same way that social networking did
when i was getting started back in 2004
and you know that's a big reason why we
wanted to
change the the brand of the company is
that you know today i think most people
think about
us as a social media company
but in our dna you know we're a
technology company that builds all kinds
of different technology to help people
connect and tries to advance human
connection and of course social media is
one important part of that
but i think increasingly it's going to
be about building platforms and
experiences that deliver this sense of
presence like you're right there with
another person so there's of course all
the virtual and augmented reality parts
of that and there's the hardware and i'm
really excited about that the work that
we've been i mean
we've been working on that for seven
years now at this point so that's making
a lot of progress um
but i think some of the experiences are
starting to come together too so you
know we've started to release horizon
and you know work rooms and and some of
these experiences where you can feel
like you're present with someone in a
place um it's just pretty crazy to see
how
um how that's taking off and it's you
know it's not just games you know games
i think is the the natural starting
point but beyond that um we're starting
to see at this point
that social interaction and just hanging
out is starting to become the the
biggest way that people spend time on
these platforms that kind of makes sense
when you say these platforms are you
speaking specifically in the behavior
seeing of people innocuous yeah yeah on
on yeah
you know let's let's let's let's
actually go right there because you said
something in there and i hope the
audience is listening seven years right
and i remember like yesterday
you uh acquiring a
meta
acquiring
meta acquiring oculus oh always tough to
know how to refer to it in the past yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna use both so stick
with me um
the oculus purchase was really
interesting because the instagram
purchase which i was really kind of
caught up in because of some of the
content i was making
the the attempt on snap all of those
made a ton of sense because you were
executing on the thing that i've always
thought you had which is where's the
current attention how do we play within
that space the oculus one was weird for
me
because i was like ooh that's
far away
why did he do that
um
seven years in metaverse people are just
now starting to kind of get going what
was the thinking of that
like why'd you do that
well i mean a lot of it is just that
you know we spend most of our days
building social apps that you use on a
little phone right and you know as as
powerful as that is you have your phone
with you all the time it's also pretty
limiting right you're not delivering an
experience where you can really feel
like you're with another person and um
in a lot of ways that's that's sort of
the ultimate dream of of building these
digital social experiences is actually
being able to make it so that people can
feel like they're there together and
doing something together and then kind
of collaborating and and just no
technology that we have today can
deliver that
so you know we've um
you know we've seen this progression
where you know when i when i started the
company it was you know people primarily
the internet was primarily about text
right so people took text into a into a
computer then we got phones that had
cameras so the internet became a lot
more visual and mobile and over the last
few years um internet connections have
gotten a lot better for everyone so now
video is really the primary way that we
share experiences so you have this
progression from text to photos to
videos
connection and expression ourselves
keeps on getting
more natural and immersive but that's
not the end of the line right there's
going to be something after video and
it's going to be much more immersive and
it's going to be something that that we
can do throughout the day so you'll have
virtual reality for when you want to go
into a really immersive zone you'll have
augmented reality to have holograms you
know so you can imagine a version of
this conversation you know three or five
years from now where instead of doing
this um you know over video um you know
you're a hologram here in my living room
or i'm a hologram in in your living room
do you think and i you know i've watched
you talk in the past and i know how i
communicate this
because it's always so challenging
is your intuition
that it is three to five years from now
that that is like that the tech between
5g which is an important step between
some of the stuff you're doing and other
people other companies and entrepreneurs
are doing do you think we can actually
i saw something i think in my feed where
you were fencing with somebody as a part
of the announcement
which looked wild because it was on some
obi-wan kenobi [ __ ] right like like
right like i was like oh my god it's
it's happening is that
is that
do you think three to five is a a solid
guess is that optimistic so talk to me
about that so i think you want to break
it down to there's the virtual reality
side and the augmented reality side yep
vr is is here right i think quest was
really the form factor that was
necessary to make it mainstream quest
two i think was a meaningful step beyond
that and is is um is kind of the first
mainstream hit that we've had um so many
millions you know i don't know i don't
know i don't i don't know what you're
allowed to share or not so don't feel
feel comfortable tell me you can't is
there public like i'm just trying to
learn how you don't have a public number
yet but it's
but it is um you know what i can say is
it's it's it's many millions and it's um
and
it's multiple times more than quest one
which which is it feels it feels that
way
yeah yeah yeah so that'll keep on
improving and we'll keep on shipping new
versions of that um so there are a lot
of great experiences there and it's been
really cool to see the use cases they're
broadened out from
games to social to now having things
around fitness right there's a lot of
that that caught my radar that there was
a lot more people paying for fitness
apps in quest than i had any clue of oh
yeah yeah i mean well think about it i
mean you can you know it's it think it's
kind of like the peloton model where you
know it's um you know but instead of
having a bike or a treadmill you just
have your 300 headset you can take it
with you anywhere you want you can do
boxing or dancing or different kinds of
cardio um it's pretty awesome so i think
that that'll that'll go for a while and
get extended a lot so there are all
these different use cases in vr
when when you're talking about the the
fencing video that i showed with lee
kiefer um in the hologram
that you're going to need augmented
reality glasses and that's a that's a
harder problem because
um first you're inventing a completely
new optical stack right so you're not
just using normal screens and kind of
building an architecture around that
which is how virtual reality is sort of
work to date um you need to design a
projector and a set of wave guides so
that way you can have glasses that look
normal and you can see through them so
that's there's a lot of interesting
science and engineering there but
for augmented reality if you're going to
wear it throughout the day it's just a
lot more important that the form factor
is like
normal looking glasses right i mean
virtual reality
do you think
i'm sorry to interrupt do you think
by the time it hits scale that there's a
chance that this is a contact lens game
not a
cumbersome overlay like a glasses or a
thick like how what's your take on that
is that too hard i mean some people are
working on that i think that that's
quite a bit further off just because you
know think about it it's like whatever
is projecting the image needs to have an
internet connection it needs to be
powered right so so i mean i've seen
some people have a model of a contact
lens that has a little projector that's
sort of like in front of your pupil and
your blind spot and it can project
something in but then how are you going
to kind of have that sync with the whole
rest of the internet and be powered
throughout the day um
what if i put five what if i swallowed a
5g pill
i don't know let's say
20 years from now i think that that
might be yeah but but ar glasses i think
we're going to start seeing things that
look like um you know
normal looking glasses but that can
project holograms into the world um you
know within the next five years um you
know i mean i think that that's that's a
somewhat conservative estimate
did pokemon go going back five years
ironically was that something you
watched carefully because i was like
holy [ __ ] this is now happening people
are pulling off on this highway jumping
into the woods to find a pikachu i would
have lost i'm pretty good at this game
too but i would have lost this bet which
was after that was such a smash hit
through the phone the fact that we're
here five years later and there has not
been another significant ar
phone execution of that scale surprising
to me what's your take on that yeah well
i think pokemon go is it it was
interesting and it's a it's a real hit
and it it is an interesting phenomenon
but it's i consider it to be more of a
location-based game
than an augmented reality game the fact
that that it shows that you kind of look
at it through your camera um i think is
somewhat incidental i think the core
mechanic is that you're going to a place
um and so you could do that with
augmented reality or not but there
certainly is going to be a whole class
of experiences that are like that but in
terms of things that that really kind of
augment reality i think you have um you
know filters face filters different
effects like that um like what you see
in instagram and and snapchat i think
that's a that's a real thing that's
that's i think is real augmented reality
and certainly i think that there's going
to be a lot more opportunity there once
you get to
um these real looking glasses that can
that can put holograms in the world so
yeah i mean i i would hope that by the
middle of this decade we can have
something that's sort of like that
fencing um clip that i showed now the
other issue on that is you need haptics
right so that way when you when your
sword hits the hologram sword um you get
a sense of feeling from that so that's a
whole interesting other area of research
and
i'm not sure exactly where that will be
by the middle of this decade but that's
another thing that we're working on
because it's it's clearly an important
part of the whole picture is you need to
be able to um you know whether you're
playing basketball or giving someone a
high five or shaking their hand you want
to be able to get a sense of pressure
back um and that that i think is just
going to be an important part of the
whole thing too
mark
when you when you make a move like this
to get the organization to this next
place
you know i assume because i think about
when i do things
oftentimes it's more for my team
internally than for the world like if
they don't understand where i'm trying
to take vayner or my stuff then i've got
no shot was that a thought about
this in a lot of ways of like hey i
gotta make sure because you're a massive
company now like is this like i need to
give everybody a north star internally
of like look no no this is what we're
doing it's not just refining the algo or
a filter on insta or something of that
nature
yeah i mean you get this because i mean
you're running a a company here and and
you know it's
like a lot of this is is really just
about uh making sure that our team knows
what we're doing right i mean running a
company is about setting prioritization
and principles for where you want to go
and um and i do think that it's the case
that a lot of times the most effective
way to communicate to the organization a
level of commitment to something is to
go say it externally right now people
know that you're serious
so um so we've been talking about this
internally for many years right i mean
we've been working on these vr devices
for for seven years um we've just sort
of steadily ramped up the investment um
to the point where now in 2021 we're
investing 10 billion dollars more than
10 billion dollars in this so it's um
it's still not the biggest part of what
we do but it's it's very meaningful i
think that there you know you'd be
hard-pressed to find any other
organization that cares as much about
this and is putting
as much energy into to building all
these different parts of the future and
what i think you get for that is that
meta has become
the premier place that if you care about
these problems you want to go work on
them right so whether that's vr we're
building the best devices ar i think
we're the furthest ahead in terms of
actually building the consumer um glass
form factor and all the different
research around that you know you
mention all any of the other problems
around there whether it's haptics um you
know or a lot of the software parts of
this where people can interact um you
know it's we're going to be the the
place where
you can build all these different parts
of the metaverse experience and then
also weave them into facebook and
instagram and what's up
that's going to be pretty long
you said something to really caught my
attention obviously the far majority of
people almost everybody who's listening
to this that runs a company is not going
to be running a company of your scale
but what you said there was not only for
your team but did i hear the undertone
there of
the fact that you put out such a public
commitment to this you see as a
recruiting
vehicle to the best engineers in the
game in this space
yeah well look i just think that when
you plant a flag and say that you're
going to go do something
you get haters and criticism
but you also get the people who actually
care about that thing and want to make
it uh happen
are attracted to the people who i think
have the courage to go say i'm going to
go make this happen even though it's
really far off so i think that all these
things are there there are pros and cons
to them um and and there's a lot of
complexity to manage but i think that
this is true no matter what size
organization you're
you're at is that you know having the
um the willingness to just go say hey
here's what i want to go build um i
think certainly creates the
self-selection dynamic where when you
say here's who i am and what i want to
go do
then you get people who want to want to
share that and what i've found in in my
career is that it's better to not be
timid about that right and to not um you
know pretend that you're something that
you're not um to try to appease critics
i think you know the more that you can
just be honest to who you are and what
you want to go do i think you'll you'll
kind of get the right people to join
your team you'll get the right investors
you'll get the right partners and i
think that's kind of how you how you
move forward
talk to now i'm going crazy selfish i
reference you and the company a ton in
my content over the last decade as my
macro thesis understand where the
attention is
it matters so much
and i often reference your m a that uh
behavior can you just give me because i
want to know for myself the insight on
the instagram deal the whatsapp deal i'm
gonna leave oculus off because that was
like i mean i want to maybe come back to
it in a little bit given the macro
metaverse combo but
specifically instagram and whatsapp
which i thought were really of the
moment deals you know i don't know if
the corporation
acknowledges the attempt towards
snapchat it was well
it was well talked about i don't know
the truth or not truth to it but
and again when i heard it or when it was
reported i was like there he is again
he's 100 right he's on it again
like
you know tick tock must have
must have been potentially a very
different thing given the china-based
guy and the complications like but like
it like
i i i'll be very honest every day when i
saw musically
way back i'm like facebook's gonna make
a play facebook's gonna make a play
right like what is am i am i right that
that is a big tenor of how you guys have
looked at the world
be
what's that about
yeah um
so there are a lot of different
these kind of
core social interactions that that
people have in these apps that that um
the different apps have invented over
time and i'm proud that that we've
invented a bunch of them um you know
going back to you know some of the core
dynamics around being able to
communicate with people in your college
being like we were the first that built
news feed that's the core social api
world by the way on the record for the
youngsters i'm sorry to interrupt that
by the way
i apologize by the way by the way for
all the youngsters listening right now
when facebook
changed from you going to somebody's
wall and leaving a comment
to this news feed
it was [ __ ]
carnage
the number one page or group or whatever
you guys called it back then was bring
back the wall or whatever like mark can
you speak to that real quick just go
back to your you know young young days
like when you guys made that move the
community within forget nobody was even
paying attention to you in the
mainstream all that stuff now
within the world immediately people lost
their mind and now that is the core way
every social network was built in
yeah i mean look i think when sometimes
when you invent these things it's um
you know i mean they can be disruptive
and i think you just kind of need to
have the commitment to to see it through
but you know going back to your point
about about some of these other
companies you know it's like there was a
kernel
with instagram and with whatsapp um and
and also with with companies like um
like snapchat i mean i think that
they've you know they they created
something that i think is really special
and is awesome um where i just looked at
that and i was like all right okay
there there is something you know
i think people often tend to look at
these social apps and think that they're
frivolous right early on and i think
that they're like these these dynamics
aren't important
and um you know oh it's filtered photos
or or oh it's um you know disappearing
photos or or whatever it is but or it's
only or it's only for college kids yeah
i mean when we had that you know through
our ipo and after when when our you know
when we were having a lot of business
struggles but it's um
but you know i kind of looked at those
and i was like hey
i think i think that there's something
that's important here i think the world
is probably underestimating this and i
also think that we have the skills as a
company to go
grow these things to reach more than a
billion people around the world and
because we've done that with the core
facebook experience and i think that
there's two skills there there's the
there's sort of the building the social
experience and then there's the helping
to ramp up a network around that and
that's that i think is also a core
competence so you know i don't know what
would have happened with instagram you
know if we hadn't bought it i don't
think it's guaranteed that it would have
grown to be as big as it is should i
assume because i'm a nerd when it comes
to watching business behavior that
much like what you're doing with
metaverse now which i think is the macro
move of that and that like in between
now and and that scaled world the
companies that have the kernels
that do best in the attention graph
whether that's in the metaverse video
so you know picture like that will
always be a core focus
yeah absolutely i mean i think that's a
key thing with this rebrand to meta is
it's not like now we're not focused on
social media i mean that's going to be
the bread and butter of what we do
that's the the core thing um and our
work to build the metaverse encompasses
both building social experiences and
building these future platforms like um
vr and ar it's got to be both right we
have to weave all these new technologies
through these social apps and you know
because you want to be able to jump into
the metaverse and a 3d experience from
your instagram feed right so you see
your friend at a concert um you know we
showed this as part of the keynote
presentation just dive in and you know
maybe be a hologram at the concert but
but you a lot of the discovery around
that is going to happen through the core
social platforms so
yeah that's going to continue to be a
focus um
we're going to keep on on focusing on
growing and building apps and adding
more social mechanics around that
i think there's a lot more to invent
there
and then i think that there's this next
set of platforms right where you know i
just you know one of the things that i
reflect on a lot
is you know social media kind of grew up
with the smartphone
facebook got i started in 2004 um
i think apple was probably already
working on their iphone design by then
it came out in 2007. so you know we
didn't really get to shape what the
smartphone was no you know we built a
lot of the most used experiences for it
but but it sort of
co-it grew at the same time and because
of that i feel like the smartphone sort
of grew in a way that it's somewhat
limiting in terms of the the type of
social experiences that you could have i
feel like there's a lot of things that i
would love to build that that we can't
build because we're we're kind of
constrained into this you know little
rectangle and policies that some other
companies set so
that's part of for me
why i have so much passion about helping
to bring about this next platform shift
and accelerating it because i think the
sooner we get to virtual and augmented
reality um the better the more magical
these social experiences are gonna be
and and i just think um
you know our platforms should be
designed around people interacting with
each other i think that's like how we
process the world as people and um and
that's just not how phones are designed
they're designed around apps today yeah
but i think you know going back to your
first question about
um nfts and web 3 um
i think the atomic unit in the metaverse
is going to be about um
you
and and and kind of the your stuff and
your friends and your connection right
so you're gonna you're gonna have your
avatar and you're gonna have your
digital clothing and your digital tools
and
unlike apps today um that are kind of
all designed to be a little bit siloed
and you have to do all this extra work
to get them to work together
in the metaverse i think it's going to
be fundamentally more interoperable
where your your fundamental experience
is that you are embodied in your your
identity your digital avatar all your
stuff and i think as a
you know as a user of this your natural
expectation is going to be that you can
bring all your stuff
in between all these experiences very
seamlessly so i think that that's going
to be really exciting i just want to
help bring that about as soon as
possible mark question i've been dying
to ask you when you first look i mean
you probably given and maybe i'm making
assumptions so you'll speak to it
obviously there was that 2017 wave with
cryptokitties we started seeing that
early kind of wave of you know nfts
right that was like kind of like the
thing that punks did not hit my radar
but crypto kitties did in 17. um
and obviously now this has been the year
of nfts the way we know them whether
it's board ape what i do with b friends
obviously punks and many cool cats many
many many projects
one of the reasons it was very easy for
me
when i really dug in late last year to
believe in this was actually because of
farmville on facebook
you know when i there was two things
that happened to me during that era farm
bill on facebook oh my god people are
buying these digital sheep because they
want the social currency to show their
friends they're good at it
and then zay frank i don't remember i
don't know if you remember zay frank
remember zay frank who's one of the
first video bloggers
he had people buy virtual ducks as
little tip jars
and have their name hover over it and
those were the first times i was like oh
my god people are gonna buy virtual
things virtual currency in my book thank
you economy i talk a lot about virtual
currency in 2010-11
was it natural for you to believe in
what's happening right now with nfts
because of the things like farmville
that happened on your platform
well
i've always been a pretty big believer
in virtual goods so i think from that
perspective yeah but i think a lot of
the the magic of um
of nfts and a lot of the web 3 work is
that
it's designed in a way to be
fundamentally interoperable so
i think that that's gonna be really
important because it'll help break down
these silos between different apps and
make it so that all your stuff can be
just um
you know more portable between these
different experiences which i think
increasingly is what people are going to
expect um but so i i think that that's
going to be a big part for creators of
making it really worth investing in
because you know if you're if you're
designing a digital good for
um for farmville and it only works
within there then like i don't know i
mean it's you know you kind of get to
the point where most of the people are
going to be building that yeah
to your point here here's the world we
live in now you're a young kid and
you're in minecraft or roblox you grow
up and you want to go to fortnight all
that money you invested is kind of stuck
in there
in the world that you're talking about
right now the the roblox and minecraft
of the future when you're done with that
you're just gonna trade it for your
fortnight stuff you're going to trade
the four night stuff or sell it it's all
going to be in that one global ecosystem
yeah i mean the analogy that i that i
like to think about is you know you i i
like your knicks hoodie but it's you
know it's imagine if you bought a jersey
and you could only use it in the sports
arena that when where you bought it
right it's like that would that would be
sort of lame and it would um reduce the
value of buying it right so um because
you know who's gonna want to buy
something if they can only use it in in
that arena i mean some people would but
but a fraction of the number of people
who would want to buy it if they could
use it in all these different places and
then if the amount of commerce is going
to be less than that's going to attract
fewer creators so i think having it be
more interoperable is going to be key to
making the whole thing so dynamic what's
interesting about that in a much more
interesting human behavior way is
people will wear it to your point
it's limited what's also interesting is
the clout the equity the social currency
carries more weight from a tribalism
behavior standpoint in madison square
garden which i'm looking at right now
than it does outside though it has
tremendous value outside
what i'm incredibly interested in is the
following obviously
i don't remember if it was twitter i
think it was twitter who did the blue
check mark first right the verification
we we've now lived through a decade
where
verified accounts following counts
social equity through visualization
we've seen it with followers and ver and
verified accounts right
the extremity of the nft space
is going to be even greater for what
that means
it's almost like our world is all about
to become the fashion industry because
we communicate so much through what we
wear
the digital version of that is going to
have an incredible impact on society
oh totally i mean i think if we're all
spending a lot more time in the
metaverse then i think we're going to
care a lot about our
representation of our identity and we're
going to want different outfits and um i
don't know maybe everyone accept me i
just wear the same thing but it's um but
did you steal that from steve jobs are
you
hard-hitting question did you steal
wearing the same thing every day from
steve jobs
i don't think so i i just think i was
maybe a little lazy
and then like had some kind of um
some some good articulation of like oh
yeah this is just about saving mental
energy but i i think um
there's never really a um but you know
what's funny i'll be honest with you i
actually think that's the punch line you
consciously or subconsciously made that
decision to represent yourself and i
think that going digital is going to be
extraordinary
yeah
i really do i really think that people
are grossly underestimating that almost
all the things we've been doing are
about to get
more
visual
more collateralized more obvious right
like i don't think a lot of people
realize why they bought a rolex i really
don't i don't think a lot of people
realize like i don't think i over think
why at 45 years old i look like i'm 13
right now right like there's a lot going
on in that and i think that when it hits
digital
it becomes more obvious i think a lot of
people's conversation
about what's going on on digital is
actually just
showing us what we are
much more than anything else and so i
think as we go into the realm of
consumerism
is insane right like when you think
about how much people buy things to
communicate that going digital and being
so in our faces because so many of these
things sit in our homes where 99 of our
social graph never sees it that going to
a full 100 is [ __ ] crazy
yeah but i think you're hitting on a
number of important pieces here i mean
first a lot of people think about this
is as kind of commerce and i think a lot
of it is actually really expression
which is the core social dynamics so the
intersection between that expression and
your identity and then the commerce
around that especially if we can get it
to be interoperable so it's a more fluid
market i think is just going to be a
really big deal
much bigger than i think people people
sort of internalize today
the other thing that i think is just um
you know really refreshing and
insightful to hear you talk about is all
the lessons from you know some of the
previous rounds of development you know
i hadn't really thought before you
raised it about you know some of the the
early farmville experiences or or some
of the stuff from from a decade ago but
but i think you're right that there is a
clear through line right both between
the the kind of social interactions that
people have um and the types of commerce
and you know obviously there's more
technology now that um that can make it
more interoperable and that can um you
know give people more rights over the
goods that they have and you know on the
ar and vr side making it so people can
feel a more realistic sense of
connection but um
but i think you're right that a lot of
these concepts are not fundamentally new
they're sort of the next iteration on on
kind of um
just dynamics that are evergreen and
that are just always going to be and
always have been very important to
people in terms of how we connect and
interact with you it's it's my take on
what happened when you were inventing
i'm like oh
people put their kids
school on their back of their windshield
to flex my kids going to harvard i might
drop out but you know like like that's
what they would do right like they would
literally like we've been doing all
these same things digital's just
exposing truths and scaling truths and i
think the new frontier of 3.0 metaverse
is going to take us to a completely
different place that i do think web 2
gave us a slight preview to
yeah i agree i agree mark uh since we'll
have a couple more minutes
have you thought do you own any nfts
have you thought about buying any like i
feel like you're going more platforms
obviously
you as the executive is platform side
metaverse that makes so much sense it's
kind of like leapfrogging i understand
that cold especially the hardware
software dynamic that i think you've
been through the last 15 years makes all
the sense to me in the world how about
you the human being have you like were
you a collector were you a comic book
like did you collect as a kid
i so i i was pretty into baseball cards
and that that um
yeah so
i had that um you know maybe a few comic
books but more for entertainment than
collection
the baseball cards i mean i was really
into that especially
in baseball i think it's really like
the um
the nerds game yeah it's math
i mean i get it you love that math [ __ ]
mark i mean let's call it spade a spade
but but have you jumped into nft land
yet
yeah well look i mean i try to use all
this stuff right i mean so by the way
real quick i'm sort of interrupt i know
i've been i'm excited i gotta give you
this shout out because this is back to
the one thing i've always connected with
you on
using all this stuff i don't know if you
remember this but when chat roulette
came out
which obviously had a 45 minute cycle
because at first it was brilliant and
then it got weird real fast
literally the first night
i had
multiple people take screenshots
because
you were because i was early on fan
pages and you were uh you were on my fan
page on facebook and people connected on
interests and you were literally there
and facebook was already a real company
and you were like running a big company
and sure enough at very late into the
night you are literally clicking around
meeting people randomly
you got it you got to use the stuff
firsthand right it's tough to just have
someone explain to you
um or like write a you know presentation
about what it's like i mean so i've had
some pretty funny experiences over the
years trying to use different different
social products um you know i mean
like probably one of the one of the
funnier ones i think is you know at some
point i decided that i really needed to
understand how dating apps worked and at
this point i was like you know i've been
dating priscilla for a long time or we
maybe haven't been married already yeah
so i was like look priscilla it's like
just so you know like i'm going to i'm
going to um
sign up for some dating
somebody
apps
and we can do this together tinder is
the greatest thing i could ever imagine
well
i i think i was on one um it was called
coffee meets bagel they give you one
more today yeah and and i got this match
and it was priscilla's friend and she
was getting dinner with her the next
night and i was like all right i'm like
priscilla just you know like this this
this um this came up
heads up but but no look i mean i just
believe that
if you want to be in the game building
stuff yeah you really should remain
curious and and keep using all this so
yeah i mean on on all the crypto work i
mean i try to try to kind of
be involved and and um and experience
that i think there's a lot of parts of
the experience today that are um you
know still pretty early right and you
know i i hesitate to say something um
you know pejorative like like broken
because i think it's you know i have
much more of the attitude of it's just
not as great yet as it will be in the
future um that's true i'm sure some
people you know they look at something
and they're like oh this isn't good but
i think you know part of the art of the
whole thing is just figuring out when
something they're they're
going to be awesome they're not they're
not historians of course web 3 doesn't
work as well as web 2 15 years later
like shopping carts in 1996 took three
minutes to buy something people forget
that people forget the cuckoo
to even get on the internet like people
forget and they're not historians and i
think that's where they can learn mark
thank you so much for your time i know
you're busy i appreciate you being on
the podcast
happy to do it all right catch you soon
you